monsieur epelboin bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
on parle beaucoup de ce fameux traçage
numérique un des personnes infectées
dans quelle mesure cela peut-il être
efficace pour endiguer la maladie alors
selon les épidémiologistes ça pourrait
être efficace à partir d'un taux
d'adoption de 60% il faudrait que 60% de
la population française adopte cette
technologie pour qu'elles puissent
commencer à être efficace or singapour
nous montre d'une part que je crois que
17 % seulement des singapouriens qui ont
un esprit corps probablement supérieures
aux nôtres ont adopté cette technologie
et d'autre part on à la 70 % des
français qui ont un smartphone donc ça
revient à dire qu'il faudrait que près
de 9 français sur 10 possesseurs d'un
smartphone l'adoc de façon volontaire
donc en l'état elle ne peut pas être
efficace elle pourra peut-être être
efficace si elle est massivement adopté
mais là on commence à empiéter sur la
liberté
justement on sait que ce traçage
numérique commence déjà à faire débat
comment être sûr que ceux qui vont
développer ses outils ici on parle
d'apple et de google
ça sera aux états unis et même ailleurs
comment être sûr qu'ils ne vont pas
collecter les données peur c'est
personnel et en faire du commerce par
exemple alors apple et google ne
développe pas l'outil apple et google
développe ce qu'on appelle une api c'est
à dire une base technique qui va
permettre de développer ce type d'outils
et qui va les rendre interopérables
intéropérables entre elles ne possèdent
un utilisateur d'android un utilisateur
d'iphone mais aussi intéropérables entre
l'application qui sera développé pour la
france est celle qui sera développée
pour l'italie ou par la belgique
c'est uniquement ça auquel s'attaque
apple et google
il s'agit en aucun cas de collecte ni
quoi que ce soit donc de ce côté là et
il n'y a pour l'instant pas trop de
craintes à avoir
d'autant plus que les gaffes et est
particulièrement google et facebook sont
aujourd'hui dans une situation un peu
délicate
il ne faudrait pas grand chose pour que
les gens s'aperçoivent qu'ils sont déjà
sous surveillance parce qu'on massive et
depuis très longtemps parce que google
et facebook
particulièrement ces deux là ont déjà
toutes les données qui permettraient de
faire du pistage épidémie
j'ai qui permettrait de repérer si vous
respectez ou dans le confinement
simplement ils ne veulent absolument pas
un terminator seule chance à ternir et
laurie dr thomas donc ils cherchent à
s'insérer dans ce jeu en prenant le rôle
de quelque chose qui est habituellement
serait plutôt dévolu à l'om est une
aubaine d'asthme internationale et ça ça
montre le caractère et géopolitiques de
ces entreprises
on n'est plus face à des entreprises on
n'est pas face à des états on est face à
des hybrides les gaffes à aujourd'hui
assument leur statut hybride et en même
temps font très attention à ne pas
apparaître comme étant des big brother
qui tient ce qui est très délicat en
termes de communication ça sera donc une
sorte d'application un salaire sur son
smartphone mais on sent bien les
français réticents monde récemment il y
à un sondage paru dans le jdd 46 %
seulement des français seraient prêts à
installer une telle application pourquoi
cette réticence
il faut reconnaître qu'il ya quelques
mois à peine
le secrétaire d'état au numérique
cedrico lancé l'idée d'expérimenter la
vidéo la reconnaissance faciale un peu
partout et que forcément tout le monde a
commencé à voir les premiers pas d'un
big brother qui s'assume et alors il ya
eu un énorme problème de timing
c'était déjà à l'origine un très gros
problème de communication parce que la
ville est la reconnaissance faciale tout
d'un coup ça rend palpable la
surveillance de masse qui existe depuis
très longtemps mais mais très
concrètement même quelqu'un qui n'était
jamais préoccupé de ces sujets là voir
d'un autre oeil
la caméra de vidéosurveillance kg coin
de la rue et ça a déjà évoqué les
veillées beaucoup et c'est sûr que le
timing du coin des rues cette
application de tracking fait que tout
d'un coup corps et les quelques cumulé
au fait que plus pas grand monde de fait
confiance au gouvernement en france ça
donne une situation qui est absolument
inextricable pour le gouvernement
d'autant plus que je le répète cette
application en deux trous d'un taux
d'adoption massif ne peut pas être utile
donc elle sera forcément mise à jour à
la bulle sera forcément et elle ne peut
évoluer que vers une vraiment une
atteinte flagrante à nos libertés
individuelles et notre vie privée
très bien merci beaucoup fabrice
epelboin d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre
question je rappelle que vous êtes
spécialiste des médias sociaux et
enseignant à sciences po paris